brad can you take us through how you lit
certain scenes for a california
christmas we have this one here where
lauren is on the phone yeah that's a
scene in in cali's bedroom i remember
it's on the second floor
and when
sean said he wanted to shoot in that
bedroom i was like okay
i'm gonna have to get an extra high
stand so we gotta we specifically
ordered an avenger stand for this shot
and then also there's a scene in mom's
bedroom where she's sick and she's bed
bound that one also we needed that
avenger stand because a normal stand
would not get us up to an altitude where
we could get a a good angle like we'd be
pointing up
so so that's a special stand we shot it
in the day with an m18 which is the 1800
watt
hmi par i remember in that moment
worrying that there was a little too
much glare and uh even when we did the
color grade i was like sean you want to
you know make that go away a little bit
he's like oh no i love it you know and
he was right it's it's it's it's it's
it's beautiful um but i'm just it's
glare is just one of those things um you
know just like a flare you know it it
can be
aesthetically pleasing or it can be you
know an obnoxious artifact and and it's
just a fine line and it's it's really
nice in in this scene that was one thing
i i thought about and but this is a very
simply lit scene i mean it was uh i
think we may have put some a negative
fill behind the camera you know put some
black up just to put a little bit of
contrast in it because that light was
bouncing off of those white walls
but um
not a lot not a lot going on there we
just kept it simple and and let that
window do its thing we also we we pick
her up with a camera move that a pan
that we pick her up coming in the door
and then we follow her over to where
she's standing in front of that window
so that's a a nice transition too
and i think that was the only shot we
did i
don't know if we did two sizes of that
if we did it was only two sizes not a
lot of coverage that was one of those
scenes we shot simple and quick and and
she just you know she just nailed it so
here we have the barn scene yeah i
remember when we were scouting
this angle and sean
saw that i mean behind us is is kind of
just a blind little cubicle almost like
a stall but it wasn't enclosed so i'm
not really sure what its purpose was and
then to the left
was
a little area with some machinery
that was kind of i i guess because it's
a dairy farm i got them maybe they milk
the cows and pump it into that stuff but
i don't know if it ended up in the movie
but that shot is actually uh it was on
some it was on a dana dolly on speed
rails so when we came to it we just
started pushing in pushing in pushing in
and i'm not sure if they used that
push-in or if they cut in after we
stopped
and it's always tricky when you're in
the shade with something bright outside
you're always kind of worried that you
don't want to under expose this and then
you don't want to overexpose that and
clip it so it's a matter of you know
finding that balance and then also maybe
bringing up the inside a little bit and
so the rim light on that was coming from
an m18 again that hmi par
and i don't believe there was any
diffusion it was probably just clean and
hard
and that was just coming from from off
camera to put that rim on him and then i
had a
an airy sky panel you know back up
against the wall just putting a little
bit of fill to lift it up i shot it on a
red helium which has the capacity to
shoot what they call hdrx
which theoretically extends the dynamic
range because it it shoots alternating
images it it it shoots
actually 48 frames and so one is
one exposure and then the other is an
offset exposure and then it alternates
and and that offset like if you stop it
down two stops it kind of extends your
dynamic range by two stops and then
there's a process in post where you can
bring that information back in i don't
think i use that here i i remember
thinking i used it a little more than i
actually did because when we got into
the color grade i don't know if we ever
actually invoked that even though it was
in some
shots
um
but again it's just one of those tricky
things and if i had shot that on film
i'd have been very nervous and i'd had a
spot meter in there just metering all
those values
but as it was you know i was just
looking at the monitor you know i've
been shooting for so long exposing to
monitors and i just trust
that if it's a properly calibrated
monitor and then i have a histogram or a
waveform that i can see the values
i've done it enough times that i just
trust that process
so i set the exposure where i wasn't
losing any information and what i may
have done i don't remember this
specifically but in something like that
is i might under expose the foreground
just a little bit you know just to to
pull those highlights down just to
ensure that they're not clipping because
i know in post as long as i don't crush
that those shadows i can still bring
them up a little bit
this is also seems like another outside
the barn or around the barn shop yeah
that's a
that is a barn but it's a different barn
but it's funny that you should say that
because we had barn as a location in the
script and they're like physically
completely different places you know one
was like for the dairy cows and then
this was more of a storage shed and
honestly you know cooper did you know
michael cooper our production designer
did a really good job of dressing it
because uh you know from the outside it
looks like a barn but you go inside it
just looks like a great big storage shed
you know so he went in there and and
pitched that hay in there it was kind of
fortuitous because it was such a big
space and i was like my god where am i
going to hide a light you know i mean
i'm going to i want to put a backlight
on him but how am i going to hide a
light
and and what i ended up deciding is kind
of like the story i told you um about
the shoot where i put the tape on the
light is i just shoved that light right
back there in the shot and had them wrap
it with black duvetyne so it's there the
light's there it's just dark and you
can't or the stand you get it's dark and
you can't see it and then up above the
frame is the light that's lighting them
when we shot the master scene i think i
can't remember if this was supposed to
be day or night i can't remember but
when we shot the master it was dusk and
so i had to match that so this by the
time we shot this it was night it was
pitch black so there really wouldn't
have been any frontal light on them at
all and what i did is i put a 12 by
ultra bounce out in front of the door
and then i took one of the sky panels
and i color matched it to the daylight
by eye
you know because again i've just done it
so many times that i i feel i have
really good instincts matching the color
and um dimmed it way way way way down
you know so it wasn't a lot of so it
wasn't super bright in retrospect after
i shot it i kind of wished i had made
that backlight a little warmer but
you know maybe that's noodling you know
they say a work of art is never finished
it's just abandoned
and so you know it's probably perfect
just like it is and that was just me you
know wanting to nudge it some more um
but it was very fortunate because it
looks nice in this in this 50 52 shot
and i was thinking when i go in for
coverage am i going to have to you know
move that light around so that it's
flattering and and like so many
scenes on this movie we just didn't have
a lot of time
we went in for coverage and it looked
pretty good and the only thing i really
did instead of moving the light is i
would just angle them i would cheat
their position a little bit to make it a
little bit more flattering so the
geometry of their position in that space
changed from the master but it's such a
tiny cheat that the audience can't tell
and it would like i said it was just
made the light a little bit more
flattering on their faces
we have the interior bar
yeah you know i was scared to death to
do this bar
from the time i read it in the script
and i was like you know can i please
have a pre-light day
or a half a pre-light day and it's like
it's just there was no way because it
was a working bar
and um it was too far away from our
location to send anybody off
so
it was like you're gonna have to do it
on the day of
i have worked with rgb led lights
pretty regularly now for about three or
four years
but i had never
lit in a bar
seen interior with them yet
and that was a lot of lights and i'm
just like you know in the old days you'd
be sticking stuff up there and sleeving
it with gels and then you'd have cables
to run across the ceiling and tack up
and hide and then you drop them all down
you know in a place that's like where
are we never going to look or if we do
look there now we're going to have to
move it so you know there was all of
that but we used the estero titans that
are battery powered so there was no
cables at all because they were rgb led
we could just dial in the color and boom
there it was blue no no gelling no
nothing and and you know our gaffer
calambarus had everything connected to
an app on the phone so he could just you
know change the brightness
turn some of them off um you know
because in different angles we would
turn them off just because we didn't
want that spill
and right now i'm talking about the blue
lights the cobalt blue lights which i
love that color i love cobalt blue and
and that was kind of an easy easy color
the thing that worried me was i didn't
know how long the batteries were going
to last i'm thinking my god you know
we're going to have to turn them off
between takes and then at lunch you're
going to have to put them on charge and
he said yeah no
they'll last and and and we never put
him on charge when he zip tied him in
that's the other thing is they found a
way to zip tie him into the ceiling
because
and i don't even know what they fixed
those zip ties to but
but i was i was also worried about how
are you going to get them up there
without you know
grip crap that we see in the shot
because you see shots where you see the
ceiling you see those tubes
but you know they look they look natural
they look like they belonged so i was
very happy about that and and the
batteries just lasted and lasted um the
red light in the back again was was kind
of a happy accident because that was the
backlight for caitlyn who was on the
stage playing the keyboard and
that was one of the rarer instances of
using tungsten fresnels
and i think those were either 300s or
or 150s that we we popped back there um
you know hanging down from the ceiling i
think what they did is they i think they
put a pole cat up you know as a small
area so they put a little like a
an extendable metal telescoping pole cat
and then they just hung those off of
there and and you do see them a couple
of times
and they look like you know little
lights but it's like oh they're stage
lights whatever we put the red gel and
and then it just motivated that from
that direction and so it was very
natural in this shot to use it there and
then for the white light on their faces
again i used
the astera titans now i just i set them
down
on the bar and i dimmed them down and
this looks like a production still
because in the movie that light's not as
bright on their faces and this is
probably somebody snapped it while we
were setting up um
but it's just so beautiful and i really
like uplight i really like the quality
of uplight but you have to be careful
with it especially
you know with women you want to make
look beautiful because
if you get the angle wrong it's going to
look like a horror movie you know you
have to find that just that that sweet
spot and and again there's no formula it
depends on the person's face it depends
on the actions with the face
um and with lauren what we did is we
ended up pulling it just a little bit
closer to josh you know to make it look
nice on her but i just i just i just
love it and um
and then in the wider shots
we didn't have it on the counter i hid
it just on the other side of the counter
so she still kind of had had that
feeling of it but when we went in for
the close-ups and we wanted to look
beautiful we pulled it out on the
counter and we found that sweet spot and
then when we reversed for him we did the
same thing we just pulled a little bit
away and we did the same thing when we
shot ali afshar for leo because he as
you know comes into this scene and one
of the things i was worried about and if
i'd had time i'd have fiddled with it i
was worried that the light on that jute
box was too bright because it's kind of
clipping out
and i have no control over that i would
have had to gel it or i would have had
to make my lights brighter um and sean
said you know i'm fine with it so we
just let it go great this is uh looks
like the
airbnb or the
hotel that they're staying at yeah so
this this shot is in the movie it's a
place that leo
rents to put up manny you know because
they want manny to disappear for reasons
that are revealed in the film
and that's the place that they're
renting out and i really i love this you
know because for one thing uh the fire
light now in this
the fire light is just natural fire
light but when i went in for coverage
again i used the astera titans and i
would use i did the fire flicker effect
on them um because the fire is really
not once you get in there and you're
filming it's not bright enough to to
light the faces in a flattering way
obviously for the wide shots i had to uh
go with what uh we didn't have a cg
budget to paint lights out and i had
nowhere to hide them so i just had to go
with available light for those guys back
there although you know now that i'm
looking about it there may be a tube
hidden
hidden down on the other side of that
fire pit
i guess i don't remember for sure but uh
anyway i just i love the the quality of
those titans when they were doing the
fire light this is one of my favorite
scenes in the movie and the other thing
is the night lighting the moonlighting
on josh and and the yard and then in the
reverse on connor's truck
you know it's kind of hard to hit that
sweet spot because you know some people
tend to over light night and i just
gotta hate the night moonlight that's
too bright and just looks absolutely
fake and then on the other end of that
spectrum is is the moonlight that's just
so bloody dark and it's like
you know you can't see detail and you're
struggling and that might work well in a
horror movie but i think in a romantic
comedy christmas movie that's just not
the place to go
um
so you know i was very happy with the
ratio here i mean it feels you see josh
clearly but it feels like he's dark
and and i love the the color shift
between the blue and the warm i think
it's just a really
pretty frame and i was very satisfied
with that here we have the breakfast
table the breakfast table yes so pretty
sure this is one of the ones which was
shot at night and we put a silk or not
as yeah maybe it was a silk i think it
was a frame of diffusion like 250 or 216
that we threw up in that window behind
there and then you see a sliver through
the door of the other room which not
only did we have to put diffusion in
that window but i had to punch more
light just to glow the ambience in the
room so that it felt like daylight
because it was just the window lit the
room was dark and it just you could tell
that something was wrong so it took a
little more time than you might think to
get this right and and by the way you
know we were talking about this scene
earlier and i said we started shooting
it in the daytime so so that ambient
light wasn't a problem then in the other
room that was another thing that had to
be added the other thing about the the
diffusion it wasn't on the window it was
backed away from the window because i
have two
m18s crossing coming through there with
a little bit of backlight so if i put it
up against the window i would have lost
that quality another thing is i'm
pretty sure it was this scene it's
definitely the scene when josh leaves
when josh when she grabs this hat you
forgot something i put a couple of
astero titans up on top of those
cabinets because those cabinets did not
go all the way to the ceiling there was
a like a a ledge
and i put those
titans up there just to give a little
bit of backlight
and this is one of those scenes that
sean likes to talk about because there
were so many people and we
had because of the covet
regulations you know anytime we change
lights or move the camera they all had
to be cleared out
so to to make that
simpler the camera is actually outside
that house there's a sliding glass door
and a back patio and the camera never
got closer than to push right into that
door and it never got wider and it never
got wide enough to see the frame so
there's a little bit of push on some of
these shots and then the other thing is
because uh the lights were outside the
window the guys could go and fiddle with
them and then those astera titans were
on an app
so in terms of turning them on and on
off and adjusting the level we did not
have to go in the room the only time we
had to go in the room is when we went in
for coverage and we popped the camera
off
the dana dolly and went inside and then
they would have to clear out and that's
a lot of people to clear out and bring
back in and then the front light you
know just to just to create that
ambience behind us um out of the sliding
glass windows was a great big 12 by
ultra bounce
that was probably t-boned because it was
um it was on a porch so you wouldn't
have gotten the 12-foot height so they
probably just t-boned it and did like
you know eight feet nine feet whatever
you could and um and then popped a light
into it and i wanna say that light was
probably um
an airy sky panel i don't remember
clearly but i only had two m18s and if
that's what's playing outside the front
then it had to be the the airy sky panel
creating that that soft light and this
is another one of those scenes where i
was a little bit nervous about that that
glare coming in that window you know i
didn't want it to obscure
um
you know joseph's mom's face
um and and so we were just you know kind
of careful we would dial the level down
because i still wanted to be kind of
blown out but i didn't want it to be so
bright that you know it was it was like
fogging up her face and again it was one
of the things that i i worried about a
little more than shawn did and john's
like it's beautiful go with it so
but that was that was a fun scene and we
spent a lot of time we it feels like we
spent a half a day in that in that
particular location because we had
several different day scenes and we had
a night scene and we had the the masters
and the close-ups
i'm sure that's not true i'm sure we
didn't spend a half day but you know
probably at least a good three hours you
know just in that particular space
and beautifully lit
thank you well this is a triumph because
um you know this was another instance
where
just like the bar my lights were going
to be in the shot and
and you know i had to fight the urge
because you know starting out it's a
cardinal sin to have a light and a shot
and it's funny i have to tell you a
story you know i won mtv vma moon man
for the moby we are all made of stars
video
and uh there was one scene you know when
we shot that where he
has got this kind of you know long
rock and roller hair and he's looking
into a mirror and and in the mirror i
didn't notice it when we shot it but
later on i realized in the mirror
there's this little red
fresnel lens i saw a bloody light and
i'm like how did i miss that you know
and um
it was red because it was gelled and i
was just like oh god you know and uh
when they announced on mtv that that
that video had won for best
cinematography guess what clip they
played
it was like just like rubbing salt into
the wound you know here's your award and
here's your [ __ ] up
um but
anyway nobody else ever knew or cared
and if they did they're like he did it
on purpose so i did it on purpose
everybody right maybe you're mocking it
so but anyway in the in the wide tilt
down in the scene you see both of them
what's just man shawn had to reassure me
it looks like party lights i'm okay
um and um
but what i did is when we shot them
because you're looking right at the
light source even though they're red to
the naked eye they clipped out and so
the white
rectangles
and i asked
keith roush who did the color grade i'm
like would you please
create red rectangles and just track
them so that at least the front looks
red which he did
so that's a fix that nobody would know
but i just thought they looked really
crappy all blown out they were really
good at lighting the space but and they
were really bright these bloody things
but they were not so bright that they
put the rim lights on kali and joseph
that is actually astera titans again on
just on c-stands with the red lights and
because they're at the far end of a barn
so i'm bringing those those astera
titans around to just get that sweet
spot and and do that red and and you
know frankly that was that was all my
idea you know i was just like that's
what i want to do um
and then we start this scene in reverse
it's daytime
and they come driving up on the golf
cart and then they walk just inside the
doors and this happens
well after we flipped around
the sun went down so there was no front
light and i had to replicate this
feeling of the glow coming in the door
and so the light on their face is not
daylight it's that same
12 by
ultra bounce out the door with a light
popped into it and
it certainly was not the uh aries sky
panels because both of them are playing
so it was it was an m18
that was popped into that and and
because it's so dim
um
you know it must have been scrimmed way
down and probably even closed the doors
some
um you know to waste some of the light
just to create that quality um
and uh
so so that's that's what i did and um i
liked it but the the highest compliment
of all
is that is that one of maria uh
the still photographers
shots of this
lighting setup is what
netflix used for their their thumbnail
and their advertising and i'm like you
know that's that's just you know you
can't have a better compliment than that
and um
you know you did a good job of picking
some of my favorite scenes there are
some others that i really like too but
but these are all some of my favorite
lighting
um and you know like i was telling you
earlier about how i love that this movie
let me show off some different looks and
different styles i mean if we hadn't had
you know the colors and the barns if it
was all in the house
you know we could get dramatic with it
but it wouldn't you know you wouldn't
have the color you wouldn't have you
know that really dramatic
range of different
flavors and so
that's another thing that i really
appreciate this movie for is it really
let me you know have have fun with a lot
of different looks
you